l' affaire s'est déroulée le week-end
dernier dans le 14e arrondissement de la
capitale un jeune homme a été
sérieusement blessé par une bombe
artisanale qu'il était en train de
fabriquer dans son appartement à partir
d'un mode d'emploi trouver sur internet
ce qui inquiète la police
c'est justement l'existence de ces sites
spécialisés où l'on peut sans
connaissances particulières
effectivement confectionner un engin
explosif sérieux l' enquête qui va
suivre le prouve malheureusement
caroline gauthier bruno bini
samedi après midi dans cet appartement
une explosion
un homme de 26 ans vient de se blesser
grièvement aux mains au visage il
fabriqué une bombe artisanale ou quand
les secours sont arrivés sur place et l
intervention de police a eu lieu il a
avoué lui même avoir trouvé serein
certains sites
la recette pour fabriquer une montre un
site internet semblable à celui ci une
mise en pages colorées des explications
ludique des croquis très précis toutes
les informations nécessaires à la
fabrication de ce que l'on appelle des
pailletes bombe d explosif très puissant
contenus dans des tubes métalliques
les chimistes même s'avouer phare et
qu'est-ce qui vous avoue sûr qu'en tant
que professeur de chimie
d'abord la simplicité des recettes qui
sont donnés parce qu'elles sont toutes
plus humble sans matériel sans matériel
sophistiqué uniquement avec
du matériel de cuisine
du matériel de bricolage ce sont des
explosifs
on peut faire sauter un immeuble avec
ses textures assez clair ces dernières
années des engins de ce type ont été
utilisés à de nombreuses reprises en
banlieue parisienne pour commettre des
dégradations sur des édifices publics
rien qu'en 2002 94 affaires ont été
dénombrés ce que c'est très facile à
fabriquer c'est un nouveau mode de
délinquance
alimenté par le par internet
les responsables de ces sites internet
risque des poursuites pénales mais aucun
d'entre eux n'a pour l'instant été
identifié